Its fan appreciation month at Screen Junkies
and to reward our awesome fans we're making the honest trailers that you voted for
here's your second place choice
From roald dol..dahl...
Doal...
Dalhl...
From creepy Dr. Seuss,
comes the classic blend of
fairy tale, horror film, and two ounces of
shrooms Willy Wonka and the Chocolate
Factory experience a movie that's pure
children's wish fulfillment but still
wasn't afraid to scar you for life that
balanced out its joy and wonder with
lessons on how adults were mostly idiots
kids were most evil "can't you shut up? I'm busy" and even good guys
could freak out at any moment in the
secret test of your integrity you lose
good day sir
Candy's good trust is bad got it! Meet Charlie,
a sweet boy reduced to poverty because
of his con artist grandpa Joe a swindler who
takes money for smokes while the rest of
the family eat cabbage water, advocates
child abuse, what she wants is a good
kick in the pants, talks Charlie into
stealing "lets take a drink charlie, nobody's watching"
has two big coke nails and goes
from bedroom to dancing as soon as some free
chocolate comes along "i never dreamed that
I would climb over the moon in ecstasy
we're on to you grandpa joe we're on to you
the late Gene Wilder shines as Willy Wonka the
howard hughes of diabetes he isn't just
a reclusive nutcase
he's also a master of sarcasm, "dont just stand there do something" help
police murder"
crazy eyes and very likely a serial
killer two naughty, nasty nasty little children
gone three good sweet little children left
watch as he turns a factory tour into a
deadly game where only the generous
survive while the impure are disfigured
in accordance with their sins and a cult
of tiny orange monsters dispose the
bodies don't believe me there's nothing
on the boat for augustus Gloop, Wanka knew what he was
doing man he knew so enjoy film
that will haunt him like you for a
lifetime
unlike the Tim Burton which will probably just
haunt you. So experience a classic film
full of unforgettable music and to help
us remember
here's Michael Bolton wait did i read that
right
you mean multi-grammy award winner
Michael Bolton hello epic voice guy
whoa what are you doing here huh
you invited me here well sure but we
didn't think you'd actually show up well
i did, cuz' have a new album to promote and
it's called storms of cinema and
whatever you guys did with Deadpool it
worked
oh thank you then let's do this
featuring the creepy man song
who seems like a nice guy?
giving treats to you,never asks for money
just a creepy hug or two, the creepy man? The creepy man
can because hes got a white van with even more candy
the dear god please help us song, oompa loompa doompadee doo, they are all slaves in need of rescue,Oompa loompa doompadee dees
Their legs are weird because he broke their knees,wonka showed up and he fed us some sweets then we
woke up in this giant factory,we cant talk back
without getting a smack, and in the first draft we were all black
Dont believe them? google it. and that this place is a lawsuit waiting
to happen song. "you'll fall in,burn your skin, in a world of safety violations
My factory has no health regulations
we dont really brew candy right,we just toss some shoes into it
every surface,someones chewed it, our chocolate river is mixed with sewage
ugh, just go to starring. Johnny depth
Joe Biden his time, when sempai notices
you
the Lollipop Guild, 90s alt-rock band
what obesity used to look like and
America. Saw for kids
wow, thanks for that mr. Bolton. No
problem as long as you call me back when
you do the fifth captain jack sparrow
movie. Ugh, their making a fifth one? I know
right I can't wait.
extra special thanks to Michael Bolton
whose newest album Songs of Cinemas
available on frontiers music, go tell him
thanks for us by clicking the link below
and get yourself a copy and if you want
to see a deleted song along with an
exclusive interview with michael click the
box to the left to watch our special
honest trailer commentary big thanks to
super fans Fronze H, Duncan K and Helena
M for voting for this trailer and helping to
make fan appreciation month. Tune in next
week to see your number one choice we
are the music makers and we are the
dreamers of dreams, there's no earthly
way of knowing which direction we are
going daddy
I want an oompa loompa now! the snozberries
taste like snozberries eww gross... you
lose good day sir